[Musique]
les aliments coûte cher on surveille les
prix on cherche les aubaines pour faire
des économies mais quand vient le temps
de passer à la caisse regardons-nous
bien le prix lu par le lecteur optique
il faut savoir que quand un prix ne
correspond pas au prix affiché en
tablette le commerçant doit nous
dédommager selon la politique
d'exactitude des prix
cette politique existe depuis plus de 20
ans mais encore aujourd'hui il peut être
difficile de faire valoir son droit moi
je fais tout le temps un petit test
durant l'atelier je vais leur demander
qui ici connaît la politique
d'incertitude des prix 50% du monde à
peu près vont me dire oui ou vont
enlever la main et là quand je leur dis
ok qui se sent assez armé pour défendre
son point de vue devant un commerçant de
sa drop à peu près à 30%. ça fait quand
même longtemps qu'elle existe ça fait
longtemps que les affiches sont là sur
le bord des casques on dirait que ça
fait partie des meubles les plus vieux
se souviennent qu'il y avait une
étiquette de prix sur chaque boîte de
conserve et les commerçants étaient
effectivement un peu
exaspéré d'avoir remarqué comme ça les
prix sur chacun des items alors la
politique d'exactitude des prix et
d'indication des prix c'est une
exception à la loi sur la protection du
consommateur
la politique dit que si un article de
moins de 10 dollars passe à la caisse à
un prix plus élevé que celui affiché en
tablette cet article devra être gratuit
si le prix de l'article est plus de 10
dollars alors on doit corriger le prix
et vous accordez un rabais de 10$
c'est une façon effectivement de
compenser le consommateur pour des
erreurs de prix à certaines études qui
étaient faites à l'époque sur
l'exactitude des prix et qui montrait
que la plupart des erreurs étaient en
défaveur du consommateur malheureusement
aujourd'hui qu'en est-il de
l'application de cette politique en
épicerie nous avons fait l'expérience et
visiter 14 épiceries de toutes les
enseignes résultat dans 50% des lieux
visités il y avait des erreurs
d'affichage de prix et de l'application
de la politique d'exactitude des prix
vous aviez les seuls messages sur la
politique exactitude des prix est-ce que
vous pouvez m'expliquer un petit peu
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé l'affichage il
peut être très complexe nous montrons
quelques exemples à l'avocate Sylvie de
Bellefeuille d'options consommateurs on
assure mon attention sur le fait que ce
produit là est en vente à 5 dollars donc
c'est le prix auquel je m'attendrai de
payer rendu à la case
et si vous en avez acheté plus qu'un pot
ben oui le premier gratuit les autres
doivent être vendues à 5 dollars alors
qu'ici l'impression que ça donne c'est
que l'article normalement est vendu du
dollar le 5 mais qu'il est en rabais à 4
dollars je comprends pas trop vous ayez
à vous battre pour ça pour faire
appliquer la politique d'exactitude des
prix faut parfois beaucoup de patience
ici on a obtenu trois effectivement
gratuitement on a fait des économies
d'environ 15 dollars sur notre facture
d'épicerie mais ça a pris 30 minutes de
notre temps ce qu'on entend souvent
c'est ah ben il y avait un problème au
niveau de l'informatique donc là c'est
pas notre faute ça s'applique pas dans
notre magasin mon n'explique pas
pourquoi ça s'applique pas
non nous on fait pas ça c'est tout le
temps des raisons un peu bêtes mais les
gens
se sentent pas à main pour défendre leur
point
différentes raisons peuvent être
invoquées pour ne pas appliquer la
politique d'exactitude des prix lors de
notre expérience un commerçant a même
retiré le prix à rabais affiché en
tablette pendant que l'on attendait à la
caisse vous devriez faire une plainte à
l'Office
littéralement pour avoir leur droit à
ceux à quoi vous aviez droit
les plaintes à l'Office de la protection
du consommateur au sujet de la politique
d'exactitude des prix on doublé depuis
deux ans mais encore très peu de gens
portent plainte est-ce qu'ils sont
exemptés la politique d'exactitude des
prix s'il y a une date je ne sais pas
difficile de s'y retrouver même pour
Monsieur Tanguy car la politique est
complexe et comporte plusieurs
exceptions comme le lait la bière quand
les prix sont rigides les fruits sans
code barre ou encore comme ici lorsque
la date d'expiration du rabais est
affichée
la politique d'exactitude des prix ne
s'appliquera pas s'il y a pas de date
bien sûr la politique s'applique alors
c'est pas simple pour vous imaginez pour
le consommateur
dans une des épiceries visitée la dette
d'expiration sur l'étiquette d'un rabais
datait d'un mois nous au total ce sont
neuf aliments gratuits ou arabes que
nous avons obtenus lors de notre
expérience ce qui représente un montant
de 40$
à l'association des détaillants en
alimentation on se dit surpris oui je
pense que c'est peut-être une bonne
constatation pour inciter l'ensemble des
équipes sur le terrain à faire plus
attention c'est important comme je vous
disais de faire l'application ou encore
de faire face potentiellement des
sanctions il y a aucun commerçants qui
souhaitent
c'est certain que depuis quelques temps
on a plus de problèmes de main-d’œuvre
ça devient de plus en plus difficile de
faire cette application là mais ça
enlève pas nos obligations
la polonais à la caisse avant même de
conclure la transaction qu'après donc si
par exemple j'arrive à la maison je
regarde ma facture et je me rends compte
qu'on ne m'a pas facturé le bon prix
payé pas trop haut pour faire corriger
la situation mais c'est en Guy il y a 20
ans
on a évalué que 10 dollars est un
montant juste pour dédommager le
consommateur est-ce que il y aurait pas
lieu de changer ce montant là maintenant
avec l'inflation effectivement c'est une
très bonne idée ça pourrait probablement
atteindre autour de 20 dollars ou plus
même avec l'inflation alors ça pourrait
être regardé cette suggestion là
effectivement là le problème c'est
pourtant la réglementation que
l'application en principe les commerces
sont supposés la connaître cette
politique là ils ont même l'obligation
de l'afficher près des cases ce serait
peut-être le fun qui relie une fois de
temps en temps pour se la remémorer une
des solutions c'est évident c'est
l'automatisation de ce processus de
changement de prix sauf qu'actuellement
il y a vraiment une barrière à l'entrée
c'est très cher mais c'est vraiment une
question de principe aussi parce que ça
s'applique pas juste à votre facture à
vous mais la facture de tous les clients
qui vont vous suivre par la suite donc
c'est quand même quelque chose qui est
important de faire valoir c'est pas
normal qu'après 20 ans on parle encore
de ceux quand il y a des fils d'attente
on passe pour un râleur on a peur un peu
de se faire mal recevoir mais je pense
qu'il faut malgré tout persister et
insister parce que c'est important que
ces droits là soient respectés